i
[Música]
a
escala en parís ahí va palau
bienvenidos a todos a este programa de
radio francia internacional y de france
24 hoy en escala en parís les hablamos
de emigrantes migrantes instalados en
europa no les hablamos de cifras sobre
muertos intentando alcanzar las costas
europeas de la cantidad de demandas de
asilo de refugiados de visados les
hablamos de historias de historias
íntimas de 400 personas recogidas en una
nueva enciclopedia la enciclopedia de
los migrantes un proyecto de la artista
paloma fernández sobrino paloma
muchísimas gracias por estar con
nosotros gracias a vosotros buenos de
esa artista ha hecho danza teatro
dirección es española migrante también
lleva casi 20 años en francia instalada
en la ciudad de jen y desde hace más de
una década 15 años me decía trabaja en
esta iniciativa una iniciativa muy
atípica e conmovedora también recoger la
voz de los migrantes a través de cartas
y hacer con esos manuscritos y sus fotos
una enciclopedia
le nació esta esta idea
pues yo trabajo en una estructura en
jaén aunque se llama las de latón las de
la tokyo y es una asociación que trabaja
entre las artes escénicas y las artes
visuales y la primera vez que me
invitaron con ellos a hacer una
residencia me dijeron tienes una semana
para montar un proyecto artístico hay
varios temas entre ellos el tema de la
emigración tienes que encontrar a gente
que viva en el barrio donde está la
residencia que es el barrio del blog en
un barrio popular y tienes que encontrar
a gente para hacer un proyecto artístico
y yo me encontré en el blog en reno que
llevaba muy poquito tiempo en francia
sin saber qué hacer exactamente bastante
perdida yo soy directora de teatro y en
el cuadro de este proyecto no sabía
exactamente qué proponer y en esa época
yo lo que hacía era escribir cartas a mi
familia en españa' cartas a mi abuela a
mis padres a mi hermana y pensé ostras
esto que hago yo lo hace muchísima gente
entonces yo escribe una carta a mi
abuela nicasia que por aquel entonces
estaba viva trabajé con una grafista
para hacer un
de edición y con esa carta me fui a ver
a otras personas que como yo tuvieran
una trayectoria migratoria y que
hicieran la misma historia que yo y de
un pequeñito proyecto que fue hace
muchísimos años pues desde ahí hasta
llegar a la enciclopedia son muchísimas
personas que he encontrado que me han
que me han contado sus historias
y son testimonios que van desde
gibraltar en el sur de la península
ibérica' que es un territorio británico
hasta finisterre en francia porque
escogió esta geografía esta costa
atlántica europea pues sí la verdad es
que es una geografía que es bastante
interesante porque normalmente cuando se
habla de migraciones se trabaja
muchísimo en todo lo que es el
mediterráneo no por todos los conceptos
geopolíticos que conocemos todos y
nosotros como vivimos en la bretaña
francesa
pensamos que el finisterre era un buen
punto de partida por una cosa un poco
metafórica poética el fin de el fin de
la tierra como nuestro finisterre
español en galicia y al principio
queríamos ir al finisterre de galicia y
hacer de finisterre a finish pero
pensamos que políticamente tenía poco
sentido y que era mejor ir hasta
gibraltar que es un lugar donde hay
muchísima historia y que es un sitio
emblemático de lo que son las
migraciones de áfrica hasta europa
les pidieron entonces a 400 migrantes
que escribieran una carta íntima y
personal a algún familiar a algún amigo
que se hubiera quedado en su lugar de
origen trabajó con varios colaboradores
por diferentes ciudades como fue este
proceso y fue difícil que la gente se
abriera que escribiera esas cartas que
fuera sincera pues fue un proceso muy
complejo porque hemos trabajado con ocho
ciudades en cada ciudad teníamos una
serie de partenariados diferentes
algunas cosas fueron fáciles otras cosas
fueron más difíciles por ejemplo si
hablo de gibraltar el hecho de que la
directora del proyecto fuera española
aunque llamara desde francia eso fue muy
complejo convencer a gibraltar entrar en
el proyecto entonces estuve como nueve
meses llamando todos los días de lunes a
viernes al ministerio de gibraltar para
convencerles de entrar en el proyecto
hasta que al final el ministro le pidió
a uno de sus asistentes hacer un skype
conmigo tuvimos una entrevista el
proyecto les gustó muchísimo el día
vargas las reticencias iniciales bueno
la historia de españa y gibraltar de
toda la vida que no se acaban sin
conflictos sobre el territorio que es
británico exacto o sea yo creo que si
hubiera sido yo francesa hubiera sido
más fácil pero bueno al final tiene más
valor el hecho de poder una española
haber podido trabajar con gibraltar
si le parece vamos a descubrir a uno de
los testimonios se trata del polaco
tadeus malinovski que ya es bueno
bastante mayor y que reside en españa en
gijón
estimados amigos del proyecto migración
me comprometí a escribir estos dos
folios sin pensarlo bien solo movido por
el hecho de que mi vida ha sido una
interminable cadena de actos migratorios
tan pronto voluntarios como impuestos
puedan hacer una declaración de
impuestos en la deportación de toda la
familia siberia por ejemplo
bueno thaddeus habla de esa interminable
cadena de actos migratorios migraciones
por elección y migraciones impuestas en
este caso deportado a siberia que buscan
en esas cartas reflexiones íntimas
políticas
lo que buscamos con estas cartas es
dignificar a los migrantes es decir que
oímos mucho hablar de los migrantes por
política por tragedias por miseria y
entonces la idea de trabajar con lo
personal con los aspectos únicos de cada
persona era una manera de visibilizar
todas esas historias de vidas y
valorizar las
hay algún punto en común de esas cartas
de que de qué hablan y a quienes se
dirigen todas las cartas se dirigen a
seres queridos que se quedaron que están
en el sitio o que estuvieron en el sitio
donde las personas nacieron todas las
cartas son muy diferentes lo que sí que
tienen en común las cartas es ese hecho
de el desarraigo vivido de maneras muy
diferentes cada una de ellas pero el
hecho de que hay como una tercera
persona que nace en ti cuando emigras no
hay la persona de allí la persona de
aquí y como un tercer ser que aparece
que es la suma de todas esas sabidurías
que el camino te va a dar y hay
testimonios muy emotivos uno que me ha
impactado especialmente es el de una
mujer peruana que vive en el sur de
españa y que le escribe una carta a su
madre y le dice te escribo para contarte
algunas cosas pero esta vez quiero que
leas mi carta delante de toda la familia
y luego un poco más tarde en la carta
dice ahora me dicen que tengo cáncer de
mama no son bueno los migrantes no solo
son migrantes
sus problemas como todo el mundo y donde
hayan emigrado no hay otra también que
me ha impactado hasta antes de una chica
egipcia que vive en él como usted que
les también le escribe a su madre
tener una hija para ti y para todas las
otras madres los otros padres supone una
carga ataduras y obligaciones es por eso
por lo que a las niñas se les castiga
con la ablación en nuestro país y tu
mamá también quisiste castigarme al
decidir mi ablación es bastante
impactante no sé no sé si a usted le han
impactado especialmente
algunas de las cartas si la verdad es
que a mí lo que más me ha impactado es
como la gente ha tenido la valentía de
escribir cosas tan personales o sea yo
no pensaba que la gente iba a dar tanto
de sí misma con estos testimonios hay
cartas que son más impactantes que otras
unas que están en todas las cartas son
diferentes y a mí todas me han impactado
de la misma manera porque son todos
vemos que son personas únicas que decir
migrantes no significan nada más que una
trayectoria en un momento dado de la
vida de alguien pero lo que me impacta
es como la gente realmente se ha dado a
este trabajo porque le han llamado
enciclopedia pues
llame a un cíclope día de los migrantes
al proyecto al principio simplemente era
porque para mí yo lo que quería hacer
era una gran recolecta de sabiduría
entonces yo pensaba en los libros que mi
padre tenía en la estantería cuando yo
era pequeña es decir yo pensaba en
cantidad muchos testimonios eso fue el
principio pero después hablando con los
investigadores en los científicos
franceses pues bueno tocar topamos con
el tema de las luces el gran tema de las
luces francesas y cómo se lo tomaron los
franceses porque la enciclopedia de
diego es como muy francés no además la
han hecho en cuero con dorados es casi
un objeto de lujo con esas voces
populares
exacto o sea es como usted bien dicen o
sea yo lo que no tenía en mente cuando
empecé el proyecto es que no tenía mente
la enciclopedia de diderot alhambra
enciclopedia de las luces entonces la
gente me empezó a preguntar pero tú qué
sabes de la enciclopedia y usted qué
conocimientos tiene de toda esta época
europea y entonces es cuando me dije
pues el proyecto tiene que llamarse así
realmente porque es como si me
estuvieran cuestionando sobre la
legitimidad de la palabra d es decir
quién es legítimo para hablar de la
enciclopedia quién quién es legítimo
para hablar de las luces de dibujo de
lambert los migrantes son personas
legítimas para expresarnos su saber yo
creo que sí y con este proyecto es lo
que propongo en un contexto de crisis
migratoria en europa de una incapacidad
de la unión europea para tener una
política migratoria común de acogida y
también un contexto político francés de
pre campaña electoral para las
presidenciales del año que viene con
discursos anti inmigrantes no sobre todo
de dos candidatos de extrema derecha
como pueden ser el isdemu imaging depp
en esta enciclopedia es un acto político
esta enciclopedia es un acto totalmente
político es un acto artístico y es un
acto realmente muy político donde lo que
nosotros queremos es reclamar la
dignidad y la libertad de las personas o
sea hablar de los derechos humanos que
los los migrantes no son personas con
problemas todos podemos ser personas con
problemas pero sea lo que lo que
queríamos era no miserabilidad
justamente los discursos que se hacen
con los migrantes la historia con una
gran h está construida de historias
pequeñas con pequeñas haches y siempre
habrá crisis y siempre habrá problemas
con lo como los que hay ahora en estas
cartas se han escrito en casi 70 lenguas
si no me equivoco 74 de 74 han sido
traducidas
antes de despedirnos ya nos queda muy
poco tiempo si alguien quiere leerlas
donde las puede leer pues existe la
versión digital del proyecto y hay que
ir a
www hubo punto enciclopedia
y los migrantes punto
y ahí se pueden leer esas cartas incluso
las manuscritas están en línea está de
introducción bueno pues muchísimas
gracias paloma fernández sobrino por
haber estado con nosotros y habernos
hablado de esta iniciativa tan atípica y
tan interesante la enciclopedia de los
migrantes les deseamos muchísima suerte
muchísimas gracias a vosotros y
muchísimas gracias a todos ustedes por
habernos acompañado ya saben que nos
pueden seguir por internet en rf y
mundo.com y en france24 punto com hasta
pronto amigos
[Música]